Mind your decisions, I'm Presh Talwalkar.
Three runners X, Y and Z compete in a 1000-meters race. Each runs with a different uniform speed.
If X faces Y, X gives Y a start of 50 meters so they complete the race at the same time.
If X faces Z, X gives Z a 69-meters start so they complete the race at the same time.
The question is, "If Y faces Z,
"...how much of a start does Y have to give Z so they complete the race at the same time?"
This is adapted from India's Civil Services Exam.
Pause the video if you'd like to give it a try, and when you're ready keep watching to learn how to solve this problem.
Now, many people would think like this:
X gives Y a start of 50 meters and X gives Z a start of 69 meters.
So comparing Y and Z we have a difference of 19 meters.
This is close but not the correct answer.
The reason is that Y is only running 950 meters.
We need the answer for a 1,000-meter race. So let's go through the calculation.
We'll use the formula that distance is equal to rate times time, which is often abbreviated "d is equal to r t" (d = rt).
Now X is running 1,000 meters in the same time that Y is running 950 meters.
Consequently, we can set up the following equations
1,000 is equal to X speed multiplied by the time and
950 is equal to Y speed multiplied by the same time to complete the race.
We'll solve both of these equations for t. And since they're both equal to the same t, we'll set them equal to each other.
We'll then solve for y and get y is equal to 0.95x.
We'll set that aside and we'll do the same calculation for z.
Z has to run 931 meters.
Now we could just go ahead and say that z is equal to 0.931x.
But we'll go ahead and do this the slow way. We'll solve for t in each of these equations,
we'll set them equal to each other and then we'll solve for z.
We get z is equal to 0.931x.
We have two equations and we'll divide the second from the first.
The x terms cancel out and then this fraction simplifies to be .98.
It'll be convenient to write it as 98 over 100, which is equal to 980 over 1000.
We'll then exchange the 980 and the y to get y over 1000 is equal to z over 980.
This means Y runs 1,000 meters in the same time Z runs 980 meters.
1000 minus 980 is equal to 20 and thus we get the answer that Y has to give a 20 meter start to Z.
I think this is a great problem because it has a slightly counterintuitive answer.
Thanks for making Mind Your Decisions one of the best channels on YouTube.
As always, thanks for watching and thanks for your support.